hello and welcome to this course on
regular expressions regular expressions
or regex define a search pattern that
can be used to search for things in a
string now this course focuses on using
regular expressions in JavaScript
however almost everything you learn
about regular expressions in this course
can also apply if you're using regular
expressions in another programming
language my name is Bo Carnes I will be
teaching this course I'm with free code
camp org in fact this whole course is
based on the free curriculum at freako
camp org it's not required to go through
that curriculum to also do this course
but it could be helpful
however this course is designed to be
standalone but if you want to go through
the curriculum on free code camp org as
well you can look in this picture where
it has the arrow right to the regular
expressions part of the curriculum so
you can see where that's at well let's
get started
regular expressions are used in
programming languages to match parts of
strings you create patterns to help you
do that matching so for instance if you
have this sentence the dog chased the
cat and you want to match the word da
you can use this regex here you can see
that there's a slash and the word though
in another slash you will also notice
that quote marks are not required within
the regular expression so JavaScript has
multiple ways to use reg X's one way is
to test the regex
is to use the test method the test
method takes the regex applies it to a
string and then returns true or false if
the pattern matches something so in this
example we have the string hello world
we have this reg X and we have my reg ex
I'm going to do dot test and then inside
the parentheses I'm going to put my
string so we are going to see if my
string contains this reg X which is
hello and then we'll put it into the
result in this case it will be true
because hello world does contain the
string hello
here we want to match the word Waldo we
have this sentence somewhere Waldo is
hiding in this text so I'm gonna change
this regex instead of search it's going
to be Waldo
now one thing I want to point out is
that this is case sensitive so if I had
a lowercase W then this would not match
but since this starts with an uppercase
W I have to make the regex start with an
uppercase W also so there's a result the
Waldo reg X test while Waldo is hiding
it's going to return true because it
found Waldo in this sentence
regex has an or operator which is a
single pipe character so in this example
let's say we want to try to match for
multiple words instead of just a single
word let's say we want to match dog cat
bird or fish so what I would do here is
I'm going to change this I'll do a dog
and then I'll put pipe which is just the
straight line up and down and then I'll
do cat pipe bird-like fish so this is
going to match any of these four words
dog or cat or a bird or fish and since
one of these words is in the sentence
this test is going to return true
so far all the regex as we looked at
matched literal strings so the case
mattered if it was a capital letter
that's completely different from a
lowercase letter you can match both
cases using what is called a flag so
there's that I flag that ignores case so
let me show you how you would do that
let's say we have free code camp and
we'll see it's all lowercase in here but
we want to match it no matter what the
case so we want this to also match this
where there's a capital C and another
capital C so just after the last slash
I'm just going to put an I so this is
the flag this means ignore case so now
when it tests the string free code camp
for the regex which is free Co camp all
lowercase the result will be yes because
they will match
so far we have just checked if a pattern
exists or not within a string but we can
also extract the actual matches that we
found with the match method so let's see
how to extract the word coding from this
string so we'll just change this to
coding and then here we'll use the dot
match method match and then in the
parenthesis we'll passion coding regex
and then if we just run this we'll see
in the console coding because it's
logging out the result see the result
extracted this work coding out of the
sentence and into the result variable
and it got logged
so far we've only extracted search
patterns one time but it is also
possible to search or extract a pattern
more than once using the G flag let me
show you what I mean we have this test
string up here repeat repeat repeat now
we're going to search for repeat and the
way it is now when it matches this it's
only going to return the first repeat
just this one but if we add the G flag
after the slash here it's going to find
every single occurrence of the word
repeat so it's going to return an array
with three elements and each element is
going to be the word repeat let's see it
again down here where it says twinkle
twinkle little star I want to match the
word twinkle so I'll type in twinkle
right here and you'll see that the first
twinkle is capitalized the second one is
not so I'm gonna have to use a flag I'll
have to use the AI flag which makes it
insensitive to case
so it's case insensitive I'm also going
to add the G flag that's gonna match
every single time
twinkle appears so you can use two flags
at once on the same regex
now here for the result it's going to be
twinkle star match and then I'm going to
pass in the star regex okay now we'll
log this and see what happens you can
see twinkle twinkle
the first twinkle in the console is the
capital T in the second is the lowercase
because it matched the first one and the
second one and return them both
in regex a period is a wild-card
character it can stand for anything so
let me show you an example we have these
two strings up here and the first one
has the word hum the second one has the
word hug you'll notice that these two
words start with the same two letters hu
and then the third letter is different
so look at this regex here hu period
this will match any word that starts
with the characters age you and then
then has a final character which could
be any character so if we look down here
we are going to take the first string
I'll hum a song and match it to our
regex it's going to return hum and then
when we take our second string bear-hug
and match it to our regex it's going to
return hug so let's try that with
another sentence we have this sentence
here let's have some fun with regular
expressions so I want to match the word
fun but I also want this regex to be
able to match the word run son pawn nun
or bond basically any word that ends
with you in and starts with another
letter so I'll change this reg x2 dot u
n so when we run our red X and search
this sentence for something that ends
with you in it should find fun
select slowed then look in the console
and it says true because it matched the
word fun in that sentence
we talked about the wild-card character
which matches basically anything but you
can also match from a predefined group
of characters if we look at this right
here
if we have the B and then we have these
brackets and inside the brackets we're
saying that the second letter that it's
going to match has to be one of these
three letters so we know the first
letters going to be the last letter is
going to be G and the middle letter is
going to be a I or u so this would match
bag big and bug so down here what we
want to do is change this so we match
every single vowel in this quote sample
here so what I'm going to do is put open
and close brackets and inside I'm going
to put the vowels a E
IOU and then to make sure I match every
single vowel and I match uppercase or
lowercase vowels I'm going to use flags
I'll use the I flag and the G flag now
down here I'm going to have to do quote
sample match and then I just pass in the
vowel regex here I run this in the
console you'll see all the vowels from
that quote sample
you can also match a range of letters so
let me show you how to do that right
here I'm going to try to match every
single letter so I'm going to put the
open and closed brackets and instead of
typing ABCD efg and running every letter
I can just put a through Z so it's going
to match every letter between a and Z
and then to make sure it matches every
uppercase and lowercase letter I'll do I
and then G to make sure it matches every
letter in the whole string so now I
could just do quote sample match and
then I just pass in the alphabet regex
here and if I run that where you see in
the console it has every letter in that
string
just like you can use a regex to match a
range of letters you can also match a
range of numbers so if I want to match
the range of numbers it will be like
this
I'll have the brackets here the opening
and closing brackets and at this time
I'm just going to match the numbers two
through six so I'll just put two - six
so that will match two three four five
six also in the same regex I can match a
range of numbers and a range of letters
so if I want to add some letters I can
put H through s so now we can see this
is going to match a range of numbers two
through six and also a range of letters
H through s so I can do an eye to make
it case insensitive and a G to match
every occurrence in the whole string so
I'm going to put that into my results so
I'll do quote sample DA match to match
this regex and here it's going to cancel
that log the result so let's see what
happens and we have every letter and
number between those ranges
we've talked about how to match for
specific characters but what if you want
to create a set of characters that you
do not want to match these are called
negated character sets and you can
create them with the caret character so
let me show you how to do that this we
want to make a regex that will match
everything except all numbers and all
vowels so we are going to put a opening
close bracket and I'm going to put a
caret the character that's right
underneath a six on a keyboard and I'll
put zero through nine so we are not
going to match all digit zero through
nine and we are not going to match a e i
o u and then I will put my flags here I
G so this will match everything except
zero through nine and a e i o u so to
finish this up I'm going to put quote
sample dot match and then I'll pass in
the regex here and now I'll just run
this and you can see we've returned
everything except the vowels and numbers
it includes the spaces and periods and
punctuation also
sometimes you want to match if a
character occurs one or more times if
you want to do that you can use the plus
character so let me show you how to do
that in this case we are going to try to
match in the word Mississippi whenever
an S occurs one or more times so I'm
just going to put s + and I'm going to
put a G to match it every time it occurs
and if I run this you'll see we've
matched the first SS and then the second
SS if there just happened to be another
s in here we would then match three
times and you can see the third time
only matches the single s because
there's only one s in a row
there is an option to match characters
that occur 0 or more times that's with
this star character here so this regex
means match a G and then match an O zero
or more times
so with this word goal it's gonna return
geo and then every o after it and then
here gut feeling there's a G with no O's
after it and since its matching zero or
more times it's going to match that and
just return G now this one has no it
hasn't
Oh's but it doesn't have a G so it's
gonna return null it's not going to
match at all so down here we are going
to do some coding and match a zero or
one time so I'm going to change the
change word here and we always want to
get the capital a and then for the
lowercase a we are going to do it a
asterisk so it can match this whole
thing of a's here so if I just do a
console that log here and do a result it
should match all of the AIDS it worked
I am going to talk to you about greedy
and lazy matches a greedy match finds
the longest possible part of the string
that fits the regex pattern and returns
it as a match
a lazy match finds the smallest possible
part of the string and returns that
regex patterns default to greedy
let me show you what I mean let's look
at this string here Titanic and we'll
look at this regex
to find something in this string Titanic
first we're looking for the letter T and
then this part means after the letter T
we want zero or more of any letter so
remember this means any letter A through
Z the asterisk or star means zero or
more occurrences of this a through Z and
then finally we're looking for a letter
I at the end so when we run this match
here it's going to do a greedy match and
find this ti T a and I so it's going to
start with a T it's going to have zero
or more letters and in with an I however
if we put a question mark here it's
going to be a lazy match so it's going
to start with the T and then remember
this is zero or more occurrences so
instead of having all these letters
we're gonna go to the zero occurrence
and not have any letters and then end
with this I here so it's just going to
be T I so a greedy match would be T ITA
and I a lazy match would just be T I so
let's do the same thing down here we
have this string here which is a bit of
HTML with an h1 tag some texts winter is
coming and a closing h1 tag if I run
this now you'll see in the console it's
going to return the whole thing so we're
gonna start with the more than sign here
and then we have that dot which is a
wildcard character so this means any
letter or character and then the star or
asterisk means zero or more occurrences
so this means zero or more occurrences
of anything
and then we end with the greater-than
sign so we're gonna start with the
less-than sign right here this is to
open an HTML tag and then we have the
dot which is a wild card
the a stroker star which means zero or
more occurrences so when you have a dot
asterisk that means zero or more of
occurrences of any character and then
end with the more than sign or that the
closing tag here so it's going to go
from here and that's gonna have zero or
more occurrences of any character all
the way to this final character here
this greater than sign so what we're
going to do is change this so instead of
it's good instead of getting this whole
thing which was which is greedy we want
to do a lazy match where it starts here
and just ends at the first occurrence of
this greater than sign so all I have to
do for that is to add a question mark so
if I run this now you'll see in the
console it just has the opening h1 tag
this is a basic regex challenge so here
is the scenario a group of criminals
escape from jail and ran away but you
don't know how many however you do know
that they stay close together when they
are around other people you are
responsible for finding all the
criminals at once so the criminals are
represented by a see so you can see here
we have these three C's together these
are all the criminals so we need to
write a regex function that's going to
match anytime there's there is one or
more C's in the string that's passed in
so this is how you would do it it's
actually pretty simple we're just going
to put a C and a plus so it's going to
match one or more C's and if we load
that you'll see that it matches the CCC
and we solved the challenge
you can match patterns that are only at
the beginning of a string previously we
talked about how the caret character
inside a character set is used to create
negated character set well if you're not
in a character set if you're not in
brackets you can use the caret character
that looks like this to only match at
the beginning of a string so here I'm
just going to match the word cow if it's
at the beginning of a string so if I
load this you can see true because it is
the cows at the beginning of the string
however if I take the word Cal off here
and put it in the middle here and I
really load that again it's going to say
false because it does not match it
anymore since Cal is not at the
beginning of the string
a carrot matches a beginning string
pattern a dollar sign matches an ending
string pattern so if we want to match
the word caboose at the end of the
string here we'll type in into the regex
will type in caboose and then up put a
dollar sign if you remember when we are
matching a beginning string pattern we
put the care at the beginning but when
we're matching an ending string pattern
we put the dollar sign at the end so if
I run this we'll see true because it's
at the end of the string now if I
actually move this over here and I run
this we'll see false it's no longer at
the end of the string so it no longer
matches caboose
earlier I showed you that this with the
brackets and a through Z in it would
match any letter A through Z there's
something called a shorthand character
class that's used to match a a wide
range of things and there's one called
/w that you can use to match the
alphabet so if I put /w here that's
gonna match capital A through Z a
lowercase a through Z the digits 0
through 9 and underscore so just doing
/w is just a shorthand way of pretty
much matching any letter or number plus
underscore if I put a G after this that
will make it match every occurrence so
if I load this up you'll see that it
returns 31 because we're getting the
length the length of this whole string
excluding the spaces in the period is 31
there are 31 letters in this string
/w matches all letters or numbers but
sometimes you want the opposite
sometimes you want to match everything
that's not a letter or number so in this
code we want to just match everything
that's not a letter or number which are
the spaces and the period in this string
here so instead of a slash lowercase W
we're going to use a slash uppercase W
and then I will put a G to match every
single occurrence and we're going to get
the length here so if I run that we get
a length of 6 there are 6 characters
that's that those other spaces and the
period that are not letters numbers or
underscores
there is a shorthand character class to
only match numbers or digits and it's /d
so if I put /d here it's going to match
the digits here which is the 5 the 0 and
the 0 to match every single one I'm
going to put a G at the end for global
and that now the length should be 3 so
if I run that will see three in the
console
sometimes you want to match all non
numbers if you remember this / D a
lowercase D would match all numbers and
the G made it match every occurrence of
a number so if we change this to an
uppercase D this is going to match all
non numbers so that's going to be every
single character in this whole string
except the five the zero and the zero so
we'll run this to get the length of that
and we get 24
we are going to create a regex that can
be used as a username validator in this
case there are three requirements for
the username so here's the first
requirement if there are numbers they
must be at the end the second
requirement letters can be lowercase and
uppercase and then the third requirement
is that it must be at least two letters
long two letter names can't have numbers
which is kind of a fourth requirement so
let's create the regex here so first we
are going to do the requirement that the
numbers should be at the end so if the
numbers should be at the end then
letters should be at the beginning so to
specify what's at the beginning we are
going to use the caret sign and then
we're going to specify the letters that
can be at the beginning which are
lowercase and uppercase letters so I'll
do a through Z uppercase and an eighth a
through Z lowercase so now it shows that
at the beginning is going to be a
through z uppercase or a through z
lowercase and to specify the number of
letters that are going to be at the
beginning we're going to use the
following I'm going to put a curly brace
to comma in curly brace the curly braces
indicate the number of times the
previous thing can match so the previous
thing are these letters and these can
match anywhere between 2 and infinite
number of times so the number before the
comma is the minimum number of matches
and the number after the comma is the
maximum number of matches so we know
that every username is going to start
with at least two letters and since
there's no number after the comma it can
have an infinite number of letters and
the username if we wanted it to have at
max eight letters then we could put the
number eight after the comma but since
we don't care about the max we're gonna
leave it as nothing after the comma so
next we want to show that the numbers
must be at the end and you can have any
number of numbers so I'll put /v and
that represents all numbers
I'll put a star so this star or asterisk
means that there should be zero or more
so this means zero or more numbers and
now to show that the zero or more
numbers are at the end I will put a
dollar sign we can now run this regex
to make sure a user name meets all of
these requirements
we can match white space characters with
/s so /s is going to match a space a
carriage return a tab a form feed and a
newline character so if I add a G for
global and run that we will see an array
of all the spaces in that sentence the
whitespace is important in separating
words sentence
now I'll show you how to match all non
whitespace characters first make a guess
so remember this is how you match
whitespace characters and if you've been
noticing the pattern so far you'll
realize to match non whitespace
characters is just a capital S so if we
run that you'll see an array of every
character that's not a space
you can specify the lower and upper
number of pattern matches with quantity
specifiers quantity specifiers are used
with curly brackets i actually talked
about these a little bit before you put
two numbers between the curly brackets
for the lower and upper number of
patterns so let's say I want to match
anything any Oh know where the number of
H's is between three and six H's so what
I'll do is type Oh No but after the H
I'm gonna put these curly brackets and
put 3 comma 6 so this means we're gonna
always match the letter O and then we're
gonna match the letter H but we only
match if there is in between 3 and 6 H's
and then we'll also match this space in
O if we had not had a number here and we
just had 3 comma and then nothing in the
in curly brace then it would match for
an infinite number of occurrences so it
would be 3 H's through an infinite
number of ages but we'll just leave it
at 6
here's another example with quantity
specifiers where we're going to match
four or more of the letter Z so I'll put
the letters E and then the curly
brackets I'll put four comma and then
there will be nothing after the comma
because like I said before when you have
nothing after the comma there's an
infinite number that it could go to so
it has to be at least four and then it
can be an infinite number of Z's
we can use quantities specifiers to
specify an exact number of matches
instead of just a lower and upper bound
so if we want to search for the word
timber with exactly four M's you can do
it like this
TI m and then i'll do the curly braces
and then just put the number four and
then BER so remember before we had the
up the lower bound then comma upper
bound but if we know we want exactly
four M's we can just put the number four
in the curly braces
you can specify the possible existence
of an element with a question mark this
checks for zero or one of the preceding
element it's kind of like saying that
the previous element is optional for
example there are slight differences in
American and British English so the word
favorite can be spelled with Justin o or
with an O you with British English so
let's create a regex set that searches
that can match both forms of the word
favorite so do fav oh and I'll put a you
with a question mark or ite
so this is this is saying that it may
have a U or it may not have a U but all
the other letters have to be the same
look Ahead's are patterns that tell
JavaScript to look ahead in your string
to check for patterns further along this
can be useful when you want to search
for multiple patterns over the same
string there are positive look Ahead's
and negative look Ahead's so let me show
you how they work
so this right here is a positive look
ahead so we have parentheses and then we
have a question mark so the look Ahead's
always start with a question mark and
then it's going to be equals for a
positive look ahead or an exclamation
point for a negative look ahead so let's
look back at the positive look ahead so
question mark equals means a positive
look head and you so its first going to
check for the queue and it's going to
look ahead to make sure there is a you
later in the string and if there is a
you later in the string will return just
the queue so when we run this regex on
the quit string it's going to return
cube because it finds the you later in
the string but it doesn't return that
you a negative look ahead it's going to
make sure that something is not later in
the string so here it's going to search
free queue and make sure there's not a
you later in the string and if there is
not a you later in the string it's going
to return this so when we run this look
ahead on the no quit screen string it's
going to find the queue and it's going
to look ahead and find out there is no
you since there is no you it's just
going to return the queue because that's
what we had before the parentheses and
it's going to return the queue here a
more practical use of look Ahead's is to
check two or more patterns in one string
so down here in this example we are
going to use look Ahead's in the pw
regex to match passwords that are
greater than 5 characters long and have
two consecutive digits so for a
greater than five characters will do
parentheses and then it's always going
to start with the question mark equals
if it's a positive look ahead and I want
greater than five characters so /w would
be all numbers and letter characters and
we want there to be five characters at
least five characters and then we also
want two consecutive digits so I'm going
to make another look ahead question mark
equals and we're going to say there can
be any number of characters that are not
digits this capital D the slash capital
D is character that's not a digits and
the asterisk means there's zero or more
characters that are not a digit but we
also want to make sure that there are
two or more digits so we have the slash
D to say that there are going to be
digits and then we have two so there
will be two or more digits so this is
going to match for five or more
characters and then two or more digits
you can group things you are searching
for in a regex with parentheses so here
we have parentheses around here so we
are searching for any number of
characters and then after that there's
going to be a space you can also use
these parentheses to repeat substrings
so this is called a capture group and
you can repeat this group any number of
times
so in this regex we have this first
group in parentheses and we can repeat
we can repeat that first group with a
slash one if we had another group with
parentheses we can repeat that second
group with / - so in this case we are
searching for any group of any number of
letters followed by a space followed by
any number of letters that are the same
letters as before because we're doing
slash one if we test this regex against
this string it's going to return true
because it has any number of letters it
has a space and then it repeats any
number of letters the same letters from
before so that's any number of letters
the space and then we're repeating the
same note letters as before now here
where we did slash one we could have
just put this whole thing again the
parentheses with the slash W I'm gonna
copy and paste here so this would have
been the same thing but instead of
repeating this twice we can just put
slash one to save space so we don't have
to repeat if we want to repeat the same
search over and over again NACA a regex
so if we look down here for the match at
first this may seem confusing what it's
returning but what it's returning the
first element in the array is the full
match so that's the the any number of
characters plus a space plus any number
of the same characters so the full match
is
and then the second element in the array
is just whatever is in the capture group
this is the capture group and we in
what's in the capture group is just
regex that's why we have regex regex
which is the full regex and then the sec
elma of the array is regex which is just
the capture group the thing in the
parentheses here so down here we are
going to attempt to use capture groups
to match numbers that are repeated only
three times in a string each separated
by a space
we want this regex to match something
like this 42 space 42 space 42 we would
also want it to match something like 136
space 136 space 136 it doesn't matter
what the number is and we only want to
match a group of three so we don't want
to match four numbers five number six
and there's just a group of three
numbers separated by spaces so let's see
how to do that we are going to use a
capture group so I'm going to put a
parenthesis /d plus that means any
number of digits and that's gonna be the
end of our capture group and then it's
going to have a space and then I'm going
to put slash one which just is a
shorthand way of repeating the first
thing in parentheses which is this and
then we'll have another space in another
slash one so this is going to look for
any number and a space any number in a
space any number so it's the number
three times we're not quite done yet
though because remember I say said we
want to match only three numbers
so this regex would also match this if
the number was in there four times
because it would find 42 42 42 and then
stop and it would say oh we found it but
we don't want to match it if there's 4
42 is in a row we only want to match it
we only want this to return true there's
3 42 is in a row so that's simple to fix
we just have to have a bracket or I mean
a carrot at the beginning and a dollar
sign at the end so remember a carrot
means that we want this at the beginning
of the string and then a dollar sign
means we want this at the end of the
string so adding the care in the dollar
sign just means we want exactly this we
don't want anything before this we don't
want anything after this so now this
will return true for any group of three
numbers not a group of four numbers not
a group of five numbers
you can search and replace text in a
string using the replace function on a
string the inputs for replace is first
the regex pattern you want to search for
and the second parameter is the string
to replace the match or a function to do
something so let's look at this example
we have this text the sky is silver
we're going to search for silver this is
our regex pattern so we're going to do a
replace you've got the wrong text dot
replace we're gonna pass in the regex
the silver regex which is searching for
the word silver and it's going to
replace it with the word blue so this is
going to return the sky is blue now you
can also access capture groups in the
replacement string with dollar signs let
me show you what I mean down here so
here we have a string code camp and then
we're going to call the replace function
on that string now look at the regex so
up here we just use the variable silver
regex which was set to this regex here
we're putting in them in the regex
directly into the function instead of
using a variable so look at this regex
we have this capture group which just
means any number of letters then we have
a space and then we have this other
capture group which just means any
number of letters so that's gonna find
this code space camp any number of
letter space any number of letters so
let's look here so up here we just put
in the word we want to replace with but
here we do something different it says
dollar two dollar sign one so dollar
sign two means the second capture group
the second parentheses in the regex so
the second catcher group is this which
has matched to the word camp so we're
putting camp at the beginning in venice
base and then dollar sign one means the
first capture group which is this
section which match the word code so
this is a way so you can see a returns
camp code so we pass in the
text code camp and it returns camp code
so that's another cool thing you can do
with capture groups when you're doing a
replace so let's get back to the easier
one up here we're going to actually make
some changes down here that follows this
pattern up here so this sandwich is good
well we are going to find the word good
here and we're going to replace it with
the word okey-dokey
so here it's going to find the fix regex
which is good and it's going to replace
it with the replaced X which is okey
dokey
this is a regex coding challenge the
challenge is to write a regex
and use the appropriate string methods
to remove white space at the beginning
and end of this string here now the trim
method would work here but the challenge
is to do it with just using regular
expressions so we are going to do a
replace but we have to write a regular
expression that's going to figure out
what we're gonna replace well let's
write a regular expression that finds
all the space at the beginning and all
the space at the end so this is how
we'll do this to find everything at the
beginning it's gonna start with a caret
which find something at the beginning of
a string and we'll put /s which is all
the white space and the any number of
whitespace characters I'll do a plus now
we also want to find all the space at
the end so I'll do a pipe character
which means or so all the space at the
beginning or all the space at the end
for all the space at the end we'll do /
s + and then a dollar sign which means
this has to be at the end and so we find
both the space of beginning and the
spaces at the end I'm going to add the
flag G here so now we've found all the
spaces we just have to finish this
replace here so hello dot replace and
then in parentheses first the regex WS
regex and then we are going to replace
all the spaces that it's going to find
with just an empty string so this will
effectively remove the spaces from that
string oh I need a parenthesis here and
let's test this out you can see in the
console hello world with no spaces at
the beginning or the end
congratulations on finishing this
regular expressions course well keep
learning and thanks for watching